[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous tombé à l'eau
il a fait jouer l'américaine valeurs
françaises bonsoir à toutes et à tous je
suis ravi d'être là je vais vous
raconter une histoire mais sous deux
formes différentes
l'histoire d'un homme de 37 ans qui
s'est construit avec de mes rencontres
au fil des cicatrices vous raconte on a
tendance à vous raconter dans les médias
ce que mon livre un sportif met sur un
piédestal quand il fonctionne bien quand
ils marchent devenir un poids que la
machine est bonne il aurait tendance à
te défoncer vendre ça va mal quand il
dérive et je pense que le sportif
mondial au niveau sportif professionnel
est une caricature un peu plus comme en
guinée dont les hommes et évoluer la
main puis la chance en fait de
rencontrer tout au long de ma vie
est ce que j'appelle aujourd'hui démarre
et enchanteur des gens et femmes et des
hommes qui m'ont permis de faire ce que
je suis à septembre qui m'a fait décorer
le rugby à paris les normands à 14 ans
qui m'a fait découvrir le théâtre j'ai
eu la chance d'être humains
professionnel à 19 ans que j'étais
starifié un temps revient cher
la chance de gagner trois finales de
championnat de vitrolles bouclier avec
des années bien qu'ils sont encore des
amis aujourd'hui j'ai eu la chance aussi
les spectateurs nous ce théâtre parce
qu'en fait sur ses six finales journaux
dates françaises
je les ai pas joué les spectateurs vers
terrestre dévie les résidents j'étais un
boîtier bourreau muer en misant en
écosse j'ai joué une pièce de théâtre
avec une aile à cali et j'ai la chance
de rencontrer le jeune femme ne s'est
signalée minuit qui s'appelle julie
village en deux vagues de navigation eu
la chance d'avoir des soeurs
mon père était bien ce que je suis
aujourd'hui d'une chance et j'ai la
chance encore aujourd'hui d'avoir des
amis que je peux compter sur des points
de vente de billets et la chance de
découvrir la philosophie la psychologie
psychanalyse eu la chance de dire qu'on
est la thématique
il a chance de karamoja août et j'en
suis sorti il ya un an nos plongeons
j'ai perdu ma mère est là c'est bien en
fait tomber les parties
j'écris ce texte que je vais vous lire
alors j'aurais pu l'apprendre par coeur
mais un genre il garder un petit peu la
scène de ce texte je suis devant le 28
décembre 2013
généreux je vois défiler des arbres sans
vie les chansons mais je perdais l'armée
sèche
julie deux ans l'idée d'une partie de
moi même je veux un petit mais
maintenant que la nuit tombe des
lumières une ville à part qu' il ya des
gens qui courent et d'épreuves plancher
un homme nu évidence juste comme étant
des devins par les domaines
alain balland avec leur père tual
acheter les gens deviennent alors moins
excentrique un marty chez les rozes et
qui aura beau mais j'ai peur à tes notes
attachées à la société qui bêlent linux
elle est dépressive madison dans la
défiance et les faiblesses alors avant
de demander des ondes et l on de sortir
de ce câble qui aliène puisqu'il a
construit tout a commencé dans un petit
village gaulois au début des années 80
c'est la chasse et des armes
je connais rien d'autre que les noirs
les gens les vagues la route von arx des
centenaires
de montbellet on voyait défiler liste la
boulangerie aux briques des tonnes de
bombes et l'arrêt de car à une première
bière les jeunes gars qui se volent des
tonnes de béton de limitation de l'union
l'a fait j'aurais les boules puantes
dans la bouche que des sacs de billy ray
canular téléphonique
je déborde en vhs l'amour a conclu pour
l'être il ya moins d'actu pour doc
martins kurt cobain et kratos la
téléphonie le dépucelage au milan ac
inscrits en 5 minutes chrono boralex à
la main début juillet lit-on également
multiples un héros je fais ma raymonde
bien installée devant la glace de la
salle à manger et j'y prends goût
macabre andy murray mais aussi chasse
aux vêtements
à 18 ans j'ai fait le grand saut
c'est la dépendance le 3 mai xinhua avec
l'enfance journaux taille
avant je me levais avec le wifi avec mon
horizon marronniers centenaires et mon
jardin voilà face à la défense elle pour
celle de l'arche de la défense un
cimetière une autoroute des universités
ou de qualité l'individualisation
commence toujours comme un espèce de
condamner ou acquitter 110 euros
merci au dessus de tout le monde tout
seul c'est en tout cas ce que c'est
totalement seul mais ne se mélangent pas
ils avancent à graignes a pas grand
chose à quoi la jeune rat des champs
je viens au pic a perdu au beau milieu
du troupeau à cohabiter impressionnant
vers l'abattoir d'un toujours un son
voisin en outre l'enjeu de base mais est
ce qu'apple jouer une quête identitaire
appartenir au pot de beurre 2 oeufs
entiers de khanabad hier matin je
pourrais maintenant d'une basse le temps
qui s'enlise en revanche pas de temps
pour laisser passer mais c'est pas tant
que c'est encore moi même ce
compétitionne jeux concurrents inscrits
additional je performe au boulot et à la
vie d'être le meilleur amant le plus
attachant le plus passionnant le plus
charmant le plus puissant le plus les
histoires les plus violents présentant
le mis à travailler en lui en refaire un
bien
producteur à qui le pratiquent le but
lucratif encore encore
où sont passés les rêves de gosse est
derrière moi je crois que la vie avec ma
carte bien accrocher les épaules je vous
dit en fait je vole ménaka pedro mais je
commence à flancher à 200 francs son
concepteur a tant donné pour faire
partie du rôle devenu comme un pétard
oubliant que la glace c'est un peu
obligé à me faire virer à cet endroit et
loyaux services a gravi un dessèchement
comme à contretemps et dernière blessure
typologie qui s'apparente à du
harcèlement moral
me voilà bien la traite en même temps
que mon père j'ai la réussite la gloire
et la reconnaissance dans mon domaine
j'ai donné j'ai reçu et je me sens vie
comme j'arrivais tout les cas de la
réussite tient c'est un superman licence
de conneries on optera pour un léger
embonpoint ceux du jeune occidental qui
se conduit des maires j'ai consommé ce n
est pas comme il fallait et j'ai réussi
je devais être heureux gérant des landes
et des bagnoles
c'est la raison d'être du voyage
mon corps me fait mal je sais que
d'autres les émotions au mental de
guerrier ce qu'elle a mal je l'écris de
challenge les belges en a sauvé une
personne impressionner une bonne
pression attrapant que laval est donc en
parler cette année la détresse en
provenance du 21e siècle et rend les
clichés je me dit vous allez m'aider
ça c'est la reprise
salon de la réalité en balance quand tu
es constamment sous pression c'est
normal qu agence amène la regrette
la solitude de l'homme moderne de
chômage m interview celui qui donna
naissance à sa fille est habile et tous
corps d un bordel je prends comme un peu
perdu entre spéculation autistes
manipulation d'être vendu millions sexe
et des croyances des gobelins conscience
des joutes aux narbonnais arosa ressent
à travers les écrans certains plongent
dans l'alcool d'autant la drogue dans le
sexe pendant les jours
obama je me suis formé dans la
philosophie la psychologie dans la
psychanalyse
j'aimerais vivre en civil
tu devenu le roi de mon monde otero
c'est vers saison que j'ai commencé à
faire un rêve aussi dans le jardin chez
mes parents et je m'en venais et deux
ans et demi trois ans quatre ans cinq
ans je prends un village prend du muscle
j'ai les épaules bien un projet 20 ans
25 ans les couilles bien accroché aussi
dans la hauteur cheval marronniers
centenaires les parents pour composter
avère que j'ai fait pendant des années
et puis un moment je ne sortirais la
propriété dont les découvrir le monde
mes impôts j'ai peur j'ai des origines
et cal le moment de me lancer en fait je
fracasse contre une paroi musiques
ibériques la propriété et le tango n'est
pas le genre de mère de l'âge de plus
j'ai perdu lustres et juste m'éclater
sur le sol j'ai besoin est niée j'ai une
phrase qui pète à la gueule c'est qui
celui des services est hors de question
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de se poser
pour vous mesdames les bonnes ou les
heures depuis tout petit nous avons un
grand effort rester dans l'âtre il
aurait performants ils ont effectué de
bonnes femmes politiques balmer il doit
être bonne tout simplement pour nous les
hommes nous est affecté comme il aime
j'ai créé cette voie les calendriers jeu
c'est une fente à ce qu'on a pu ouvrir
la sélection suis vraiment sincèrement
désolé un crétin de fantasmes
depuis tout petit j'ai l'impression
d'avoir couvert des parents des
professeurs et maintenant que je suis
capable est grande et fort ne pas être
désolé d'être le premier capitaine
compétition vers pois verts qui est
gagnant et qui m'apprend accord en moi
qui n'apprend à croire en l'autre dans
sa différence qui m'apprend à me voir
parce que je suis véritablement la
réponse arrive à sa connaissance 2007 ne
rencontre au point d'une bibliothèque à
merlin l'enchanteur may cry sur une
petite serviette en papier ce qui va
révolutionner mon quotidien
tu as été dans le paraître pendant 27
ans il va falloir que tu es découvrit
avec situe véritablement à l'intérieur
je croise à partir de ce moment là que
j'ai perdu mon humour économie mon
innocence
ils réapparaîtront p 10 heures plus tard
oratoire la maison familiale pour les
fêtes je m'assois presse à cette classe
devant laquelle j'étais ton pendant des
années mais la mort fait débouler
michael barrett est ces motos en boucle
alors que ma mère pour rire me lance des
narcisses visage face à son miroir mais
je me sens rue des trois grâces de
guignol le miroir celui de mon team en
associant ses copains je me permets la
solitude schizophrénique à la recherche
de ma mère ma vie est entrecoupé d'une
histoire d'amour avec une jeune femme
tout aussi fort que moi il va subir mes
mots mes questionnements dans quelque
sens l'enfer de l'intention de partager
ce que ce petit train petit à petit je
tiens compte plus d'un millier rudiments
qui donnent plus qu'ils ne le libère je
deviens dogmatique utilisent des
théories formation est née chez
complètement désincarné je t'envoie un
message à travailler aux restos du coeur
vainqueur 6-3 de développement personnel
parce que belgique si je terminais aulas
l'usurpatrice terrorisé m'a dit je la
regarde en face c'est les oreilles dans
le ciel terre et 15 jours c'est
peut-être un peu cherche à sauver en
fait je peux pas vous petit à petit en
déstructurant le moins qui va un peu
trop petit à petit en déstructurant le
monde comme invendus et dans lequel je
faisais anglais la messe dans cette
jeune femme celle qui abrite un point
dakar est en pleine tronche décidé de
plaquer un jeu insolite et 200 en 2013
est ce que le dire que mardi matin mois
le lion - legrand oneworld intelligente
plus sympa le plus drôle voit le
comportement et les actrices comme un
cassandre ont écouté ce code ngp à
titiller les émotions dont je m'étais
coupé décalé de parts en larmes cris a
patiné
je pleure je m'arrache les musiques jeux
remis mes cicatrices qui m'a transformé
et donc ses mains tard ses politiques
ses médias ces religieuses un tableau de
mai a consisté minimum 120 heures nous
aurons
isolé ne pleure pas nous en batterie
soit là soit fort et rares prétendants
l'argent la gloire la possession le
pouvoir en l'absence de t'accueillir
muscles tout travailler va bosser
objectif tout qu'il réponde a très envie
qu'un jour plus grande enfant roi de
cosmétiques soit et l'ayant le peuple
pour le collector tobin et contrôlent un
extrême doit à l'infini thèse plus qu'un
discours appartenait au clan d'efforts
auckland et hop voilà sera vendue à issy
d'aspirine mon cul c'est un cinéma that
de fantasmes ce cliché dignité et un
moment cette incurie la rapidité
galopante orange la pologne qui veulent
jusqu'à le mettre les nerfs à vif
laval inc est à chaque coin de rue
région que la dissolution les cicatriser
les blessures on l'entendait de mes
ancêtres et et son époque tu revenais
pas morte de montbard être mais seront
occultées de comprendre leurs mots qui
vont lui apporter un changement sans un
gros gilet temps présent d'oublier les
rappeurs et des biens bros passé mais
transpirer terrain tu d'inventer les
chimères seul j'entre dans la torre en
pleine nuit pour combattre les promos
démonter un jeune rat thomas qui se
décrit lui a remis en route soit
protection
makam serrer la main doré est choisie
tomber encore la police attendait
saurait prendre le risque de continuer
de rouler encore de gamme les humains je
suis mort le 28 décembre 2013 certes
mais un grain à grain et à la
renaissance
mais samedi soir descend de la montagne
je sors de ma caverne quelques mois plus
tard en guise angel les personnes ont
été blanchies déjà benoît et peuplant
les marines je racontais un petit à
petit cette jeune fille que tu que je
veux et mais bon ce qu'elle est on
achète alors un canapé une machine à
laver ont inscrit qu on se découvre en
avant assez mais différemment j'ai plus
de 4 en début d'année s'est plaint
d'avoir été plantés coloré superman
batman mais c'est à tomber starifié
dépressif scarifie à braga était docteur
jeckyll et mister hyde
captain ricardien
un apprenti bon gros but écossais après
qu'un bon gros connard rugbyman jusqu'à
la mort
un gamin dans un corps de grands ados
aura été un enfant meurtri ses plus
beaux parents après avoir été car quand
tu apprends cap et matériels son visage
de bouffe dégueulasse depuis le plan de
violence alors été aussi bon oeil sans
mal de reconnaissance un train du stade
pour avoir été percés ignorer mystifié
alors a été un peu moins philosophe
narcisse un branchement un dogmatique un
révolutionnaire l'utopiste à sauveur à
l'anarchisme un mauvais père juppé
elle va avoir abandonné le mal comme à
effet et après avoir demandé pardon pour
les mâles engendrer je vais devenir
tabac le 6 mars 2007 avait alors 28 tu
es arrivé sur cette période
mais c était le plus beau de l'onu qui
s'était demandé aujourd'hui nos vies
cette année et moi nous voilà bel et
bien responsable dans l'hérault qui est
évidemment un motif que les biens
assurés abordés elle et sa mère qu'il ya
des aliments dont trois triathlons et
dire que nous les hommes à ce concours
des cadors des comptes des pour
l'enchaîner cinq compétiteurs
il est sage femme entre dans la salle
d'accouchement et tu te mets à pleurer
il navigue entre terriens et moi entre
ta mère et à la douleur mais si heureuse
je chiale moi aussi par la ration qu'il
a bien tué et un projet tellement beau
on ira titiller qu'il ya cette année
trois matches où tu n'as que ça à mieux
vivre d entrain de terrain tu pleures je
sais pas quoi faire de cet infirmier qui
ont dit qu'ils deviennent avait au même
moment la série dure non madame non non
la philibert a pas cinq minutes
elle vient déjà de cracher ce beurre
mais moi aussi j'aime quand est ce que
je vais bien pouvoir apporter de l'amour
découvrez ce que sa mesure
on fige et à prendre conscience de la
richesse humaine et noir celles des
autres oser être soi ça s'apprend sinon
je peux me tenir sclérosé votre canapé
insulté dans ce
bouger sinon creed et colas est
rancunier les cafards bonne odeur de son
démon mimant avaler dans l'arène ap ap
par la colonie et qu'ils vomissent leur
et du monde sans même se rendre compte
qu'ils en sont responsables de par
l'ordination je sais de quoi je parle
gfr j'étais comme ça c'est un vieux pote
d'avoir peur alors si on compte les
besoins janet la boîte maurice est un
petit conseil si tu as des nerfs des
projets de voler les coups de pinceau
qui subiraient papa c'est impossible
ils veulent te garder pour eux nous ont
rassurés d'avoir raison et continuent à
se répéter par un système qui empêche
les solidaires ce sont leurs pleurs et
l'état martèle parc grec monfils fait
capables de nous observerons la nature
ressent vivre dirait vous regarde les
choses avec attention et par extension
mais c'était mon passé pour l'écrire en
voiture en à patrouiller avec
toi mon fils aujourd'hui je viens à elle
suit dans un jardin chez des parents et
je m'envole de deux ans et demi elle
prend de l'âge prend du muscle je prends
de la hauteur sur un marronnier
centenaire j'ai dans ma main gauche ce
petit m2 an et demi j'étais dans la
droite n'a pas de mots gosse et mes
gosses plus tard chez les parents qui
sont à côté de moi ma mère et mon père
j'ai laissé mes amis et en fait ils ont
fracassé plan la musique ensemble et à
la réponse a qui sont en fait je pense
que je suis en 2001 si vous étiez les
ponts et d'écoles que ce qu'apparaissent
gt1 qu'on vous auriez pas là donc si on
arrive à surmonter nos peurs
si on arrive à accepter nos différences
je pense qu'on peut écrire lecture au
présent mais pourquoi pour ça je pense
qu'il resserré sur la même et l'autre
dans sa différence
on s'appelle la confiance en soi
souhaite un bon voyage à tous et à toxic
ainsi notre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]